Many men have worn the cowl since the very
first Batman film hit the big screen, and
every Batman actor has brought a different
point of view and a different feeling to the
role.
The tones have spanned from angst-filled drama
to sly, suave crime capers, and it seems as
if there are hundreds of different ways to
play the Caped Crusader.
Just before "Twilight" star Robert Pattinson
took on the Dark Knight for this year's "The
Batman," there was Ben Affleck, who was Bruce
Wayne and his gloomy alter ego in both "Batman
v. Superman: Dawn of Justice" and "Justice
League."
Affleck has always been outspoken about the
reason why he took the role on — and the
reason why he departed "The Batman" before
it went into production, which allowed for
Pattinson to board the project.
The actor told The New York Times in 2020,
"I showed somebody 'The Batman' script.
They said, 'I think the script is good.
I also think you'll drink yourself to death
if you go through what you just went through
again."
But when he left the role, he ended up changing
the project in a completely unexpected way.
How did Affleck's departure from "The Batman"
end up changing the face of the film forever?
Per a February 2022 New York Times article
about "The Batman" director Matt Reeves, the
original version of the film was to feature
Ben Affleck's version of Bruce Wayne.
The film was slated to take a look at Batman
through a different lens — that of an older
Wayne, more mature, instead of a young trust-fund
heir covering up his vigilantism with an unmasked
life as a devil-may-care playboy.
Affleck was also supposed to write and direct
the movie but eventually decided that he would
simply act in the film.
Reeves himself eventually co-wrote the version
of "The Batman" which he would one day direct,
along with co-writer Peter Craig of "Bad Boys
For Life."
Reeves then entered the picture after multiple
directors were suggested, and he said the
script he was presented with was "an action
set-piece adventure."
In the time it took for Reeves to complete
the final film in his "Planet of the Apes"
reboot trilogy, 2017's "War for the Planet
of the Apes," Affleck had left the project.
Reeves said to The Times,
"I think Ben was just evaluating what he wanted
to do and it wasn't what I think he had fallen
in love with, in terms of playing that character
in the first place."
But his departure definitely affected the
future of "The Batman," as that meant Reeves
now had to forge ahead without his leading
man.
He chose to do this in a way that would both
honor Batman's long past and push him to new
and different heights.
And Reeves and Craig would have to be the
ones to take him there.
In the wake of Ben Affleck's leaving the project,
Matt Reeves' goal was to present a Batman
who would be changed completely by the events
of the film.
Reeves told the New York Times,
"I wanted the stakes of the story to challenge
him in a way that shook him to his core."
Instead of a movie about a "disillusioned"
Wayne forced to face that his vigilante ways
weren't getting the job done, the movie would
now center around, quote, "someone who hadn't
quite figured out why they were doing the
thing they were doing."
Reeves continued to say that for his version
of Bruce Wayne,
"He's still stuck in those events that happened
when he was 10."
With this in mind, the project zeroed in on
a time period several years into his life
as Batman.
Soon enough, Reeves had his new Batman in
Robert Pattinson — a choice that Affleck
ultimately approved of, calling Pattinson
a "good actor" during an interview — and
the rest of the production's pieces slowly
fell into place.
It isn't the film that fans would've seen
had Affleck still been Batman, but it definitely
seems to be a worthy entry.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Batman
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.